[Music]
welcome to making a IML simple fast and
cost-effective with google kubernetes
engine my name is Marlon Patel I am the
product manager at Google cloud and I'm
very pleased to introduce our
distinguished colleague from bhg a
digital Mahadevan and Rolly thanks
Mullin hi my name is Mahadevan I'm a
principal data scientist at BG digital
I'm a mechanical engineer and have a
deep focus in working on system level
modeling and building analytics hello
good afternoon I know it's a it's right
after lunch and a little nap makes it
easy nice but it's Cuban it is okay it's
exciting
okay let's get started anyway I'm
morally I'm a principal analytics
advocate with bhe my primary focus is on
data and infrastructure I work with the
customers basically in moving the data
to antrum or cloud wherever it is and
making it consumable and then handing it
off to the data scientists like my they
want to do their magic thank you thank
you both of you so let's get started
so today we are going to talk about two
hot topics in the computer industry
first is artificial intelligence and
machine learning and second is
kubernetes both are critical pillars in
today's modern computing environment in
today's digital economy data is the
currency for many of us data is the
lifeblood of our company and we want to
convert data into meaningful information
actionable intelligence AI ml is the
engine that helps us convert the data
into actionable intelligence and with
the actionable intelligence we can make
better business decisions and drive
actions in our organization industries
all around the world are investing very
heavily into a IML capabilities at
Google our mission is to make a IML
simple fast and cost-effective we want
to make AML simple so everyone in your
organization can benefit from it we want
to make AML fast so you can build a
model fast train them fast deploy them
farts and get insight faster we also
want to make AML cost-effective in order
to democratise a IML so that it's
accessible to everyone so when we think
about
AML we typically think about building
models and training models but in
reality UML involves a lot more than
building and training models typically
the ML code is a very small part of the
end-to-end
KML to change we need to recognize that
AML is a team sport a lot of skills are
needed in order to build and to an AI ml
application for example a data engineer
may gather the data and cleans the data
another engineer may extract feature out
of the data a data scientist may build a
model an application engineer may
convert the model into application api's
and an end user may use the model milled
using those api's so anyone who has ever
tried to build an AML team knows that
there is a shortage of AML skills so how
can we make these scarce resources 10x
more productive how can we give them an
environment that helps them you know
wait faster
that's why we have built cloud native
KML platform so world is moving towards
cloud native computing and kubernetes is
the de facto standard for orchestrating
containerized workload we have brought
the power of kubernetes to the world of
AI ml kubernetes makes a IML workflows
simple composable and scalable
with the help of kubernetes platform our
data scientists can train and deploy
model without having to worry about
underlying infrastructure simply choose
your favorite ml framework pack the
model up into containers and deploy them
on kubernetes at scale kubernetes will
scale your models from a single node to
the thousands of known depending on your
computer requirement it will make you
more productive and the best part is it
you will be able to reproduce results
reliably across the platform so let's
think about why kubernetes in an ideal
platform for building AI ml toolchain so
there are three core reasons why
first is portability kubernetes enables
cloud native open standard ide api which
means you can choose seamlessly port
your workload between cloud and laptop
and your own private data center without
having to change your source code number
two it makes your workload scalable you
can scale from a single node to
thousands of nodes also community
supports hardware accelerators such as
GPUs and Tipu's and provides you higher
level abstractions like auto scaling or
auto provisioning which makes scaling
your workload super simple and easy and
number three is productivity it with the
help of kubernetes you can free up your
users from managing their own
workstations or VM as a data scientist
and data NGOs you can focus on your core
mission which is to basically build and
deploy models without having to worry
about underlying infrastructure so if
you're a data scientist you are
wondering do I have to master the
kubernetes kill in order to benefit from
all these features great news you don't
have to master those skills data
scientists typically build their model
inside the notebooks they have the
preferences for their libraries and
machine learning frameworks to make
their work super simple and easy we are
providing host
notebooks and our hosted notebooks are
pre-configured with one of the widely
used libraries like pandas and also many
other machine learning frameworks like
tensorflow Chara's and many many more
all you have to do is open up your
browser connect to your data and start
building models inside your notebooks
the best part is you can train the model
and the deploy your model on the top of
kubernetes directly from your notebook
you don't even have to leave the
notebook so you get very notebook
friendly experience and all the benefits
of kubernetes so what if you are an
expert kubernetes user great news
kubernetes also provides you higher
level abstraction that helps you run
tensorflow jobs very simply and easily
for example you can make use of TF job
with the TF job does is it integrates
tensorflow distributed training and
estimator api's with kubernetes and it
allows you to scale training and
leverage the hardware accelerators which
work with kubernetes as a user you can
benefit from a very vibrant ecosystem of
communities products that are out there
when you work and develop your models on
the top of kubernetes you can use
kubernetes dashboards for monitoring or
Prometheus and Griffon and many many
other tools which community have
developed over many years so kubernetes
also makes tensorflow serving super
simple and easy so let's say you build a
very sophisticated movie recommendation
engine now you want to test your model
on a small scale with the global traffic
now if you deploy your model in u.s. the
traffic will be overwhelming from the
audience which loves Hollywood movie if
you deploy this model in India the
traffic will be from all rel mainly from
the audience which loves Bollywood movie
so you have a dilemma on the one hand
you want to test your model through a
global process
of the traffic on the other hand you
don't want to deploy your morale
globally which because it's an
experimental model and you're concerned
about the blast radius of something
going wrong so what do you do here again
kubernetes and sto come to the rescue
with the help of kubernetes and sto you
can actually configure the your load
balancer so that your model gets a
cross-section of the traffic from many
many different regions so you can test
the fidelity of your model across the
regions without having to deploy your
model globally so what it means is
kubernetes helps you address many model
rollout challenges it makes model
lifecycle management super simple and
easy so so far i talked about how
kubernetes simplify model building but
the biggest challenge is model training
we have seen time and time that building
a complex model takes really really long
time mainly because it takes very long
time to train them so in order to
expedite the model training we have
brought the power of GPUs to the
kubernetes so with the help of GPUs you
can turbo charge your compute intensive
applications we've support a wide range
of GPUs in google kubernetes engine and
they have a different cost versus
performance profile so you can choose
the GPU that's best suits your
application needs and your budget you
can get started with a kubernetes GPU
k80
which we support which gives you entry
level performance at the lower cost but
if you decide to turbocharge your
application you can use v100 which is
very powerful GPU and allows you to
expedite your model building and model
training as well as model serving and
the best part is that GK also supports
preemptable GPU so for your batch
workload you can reduce the cost by 50
to 70 percent by using preemptable GPUs
so we also offer you
many more choices for hardware
accelerators to accelerate your machine
learning workload so for example on
Google Cloud gke we also support Google
design hardware accelerators which we
call cloud TPU
which will further accelerate your AI ml
workload while reducing the cost Lam
super pleased to announce that our
third-generation cloud TP use version 3
are now generally available on google
kubernetes engine starting today so you
can access those very powerful cloud
CPUs just like you will access CPUs and
GPUs on gke you you don't have to manage
them on your own
google kubernetes engine actually
manages them for you also the best part
they are available as a preemptable load
which means you can substantially reduce
the cost of batch training by using
preemptable cloud TP use google
kubernetes engine also supports cluster
autoscaler
with GPU ntp use so with the help of
cluster or a scaler you can
automatically scale up and down the
clusters for best performance or cast so
nodes with GPU and TP you get created
when you need extra compute capacity you
don't have to manually schedule them and
the nodes with GPU ntp you get deleted
when they are idle so you get two core
features on demand extra compute without
you having to manually schedule them and
number two freeing up the resources when
they are not used which means you don't
have to pay for them so it optimizes the
cost and gives you like a super
computing powers without manual work now
let's look at a real world example what
would be a better example than a
software program that defeated world
champions and professional go players
this was a historical milestone in the
history of artificial intelligence when
a software program defeated vol
champions so for those who are familiar
with gogo is a strategy board game which
was invented more than 2,500 years
ago and ever since he does it has
captivated human mind it is played on a
19 by 19 board and players actually
alternate placing the stones on an empty
cross-section and a player that
surrounds more territory actually wins
so goal is incredible difficult program
for computer to learn and here is why
just imagine that the number of board
configurations that are possible on a
goal board are actually more than number
of atoms in the universe number of atoms
in the universe so just a brute force
approach does not work number two for
every move you have too many choices
available and its impact is realized
over a large horizon which makes it very
very difficult for computer to analyze
three and number three unlike chess
which has like a rules when the game is
over for example one player check match
the other go has no rule where it
dictates the termination of a game game
is over when two parties agree which
means it's very difficult for computer
to analyze when the game is over right
so alphago zero was the first program
which defeated the professional go
player and I'm going to talk about min
ago which is an open source independent
implementation of the alphago zero so
let's see how go algorithm is
implemented so mini go is actually
implemented using reinforced learning
algorithm so in the Lillie reinforced
learning there are two critical steps in
the first step the model plays against
itself which is called a self play and
it records the search space search space
for every move in the second step the
data that is gathered in the first step
you use to train the model and make the
model better now again this better model
plays against itself to create more data
and this more data is used to create
even better models so this loops keeps
repeating and model gets better and by
and better now remember every go game
has hundreds of move and for every move
the model has to do inference for
thousands of search spaces so the amount
of compute that is needed for inference
actually Dwarfs
the amount of compute needed for
training so inference is the biggest
bottleneck you can see in this picture
self play arrow is much bigger than the
training error it's on purpose
so how can we basically make sure that
this game can be trained in a short
amount of time so the great news here is
that all these games can be played
independently in parallel because they
are completely independent so using that
we implemented the mini go on the top of
GK Google kubernetes engine and initial
implementation used to take more than a
couple of months to train now imagine
you want to experiment with that you
start a training and then says come back
in five months when training will be
over that would be quite frustrating
isn't it so with the help of cloud TP
use we could scale down the training
time on the top of google kubernetes
engine - just a couple of days so after
we fully trained it the model used to
play millions of games and every single
day every second 15 to 13 games can be
played with this advanced feature we
could devote up 250 patter flip-flops or
compute to a single problem very easily
so how to use are incredibly powerful
machines so this is a picture of cloud
TPU version 2 and we used it to train a
very well-known model which is raster at
15 on image net data set and with one
single cloud TPU which has eight core we
could train the entire rosin 850 model
in under nine hours and the best part
was the total cost was little under $39
and if we use a preemptable TPU the car
was almost 1/3 little under $13 so in
$13 you have a supercomputer at your
disposal to train very complex model
isn't that incredible and with version 3
and using many many chips in parallel in
this case thousand 24 chips in parallel
we could train ResNet 50 model on image
net data set up to seventy six point
three percent accuracy in just two point
two minutes it's just mind-blowing to
think that this machine could process 1
million images per second more than 1
million that's just amazing you could
train models in 2 minutes by the time
you drink your coffee so it will save
you so much time you can do so much more
with your time do something interesting
instead of waiting for model to finish
so in order to help you get started
quickly Google provides many open-source
references for cloud TP use and with
this open source references you can
solve many real-life problems for
example you can create image recognition
algorithms or you can create machine
translation or do speech recognition or
image generation or many many different
things all you have to do is bring your
data use the existing model to train
them and you're on a great start but if
you choose to decide to work on a
special problem you can always write
something from scratch using the
libraries that are made available and we
support many many different frameworks
so you can get started with all the
tutorials and knowledge that is built in
the community of our tensorflow scare us
in many many different frameworks so now
let's hear from b.i.g digital about
their experience and their journey of
building AI ml algorithms and models on
the top of kubernetes modern thanks
Mullin so in this portion of the
presentation we'll actually go over our
team's experience with using GK in
particular we will share some of the
best practices that we followed so that
we can actually leverage all
resources with commission and it's
actually simple fast and cost-effective
so just to give a scale of the type of
problems that V as a larger G you face
in every two seconds a plane with the G
engine takes off somewhere in the world
nearly 30 percent of the world's
electricity is actually made by a G
turbine coming more closer to home
v our Baker Hughes we are an oil and gas
company so this is the world's first
full stream company which actually takes
care of exploring oil extracting oil
transporting and refining all the way
through the entire lifecycle of oil so
in order to sort of manage all these
assets properly we have to deal with a
lot of models we are talking of
thousands of models for us a model is
something which links inputs to its
outputs we so how do you sort of build
these models so in this case we leverage
the same framework that Mullen mentioned
where we use GK that is sitting on top
of the hardware layer and we utilize the
framework that we kind of started off at
Baker Huw call the depend on docker so
this helps and analytics engineer to
package their analytics into containers
so it gives a sequence of scripts and a
process that can help institutionalize
how analytics could be built run tested
and deployed so all the analytics would
be actually packaged as containers and
that would actually feed the
applications that you see at the top so
the applications would range from data
management we deal with a lot of data
which we'll talk about soon also a lot
of other applications where we deal with
anomaly detection just to find if a
system is operating normal or abnormal
is it time to shut it down or do some
preventative action over it there are
lots of other concepts of applications
where we deal with the amount of
remaining useful life that and that a
part has and definitely optimizing the
operation in order to do this we need to
have all these applications and now we
let us look at what is a cost of a false
prediction a false prediction
our kiss can actually mean we need to
shut down a plant or probably we need to
sort of tell a plane cannot take off and
it'll be stuck at the tarmac the results
are pretty cost sensitive and we are
going to actually lose a lot of money in
the process
therefore we strive a lot to actually
get very accurate models so how do you
build accurate models we do have to
build safer and a model for a small
asset we are looking at around five or
six engineers who would spend around a
month or two to make a model that is
pretty accurate now if I were to scale
it for an entire plant or a refinery I'm
talking about thousands of models no way
this model can be scale or this
traditional way of bringing in more
people and trying to sort of like build
models cannot scale and and on the other
flip side it is not as simple of
commissioning more nodes and clicking a
button and say go for the models to be
created so we need to do something
different and proper to sort of use
leverage all the machines that we
commissioned so what we will highlight
in the subsequent presentations are the
things or the bottlenecks that are there
in the process and how we overcame that
so that we'll be able to build these
models at scale while still being
cost-effective so let us focus on the
first example where we call where we
look at the data wrangling exercise so
we deal with a lot of data here so we
are if we take a simple machine a simple
refinery we are looking at around three
thousand sensors or so that is
generating data the sensors can be
generating data at different rates it
can be in seconds some can be in minutes
few seconds etc so all these data has to
be connected and therefore for the three
thousand sensors over a two year period
we are talking about trillion rows of
data this is pure raw data and this raw
data needs to be sort of converted into
some workable data that can be fed into
the analytic correct and so that you can
also expect different analytics would
need the data at different rates so you
need to prepare different sets of data
off to feed different analytics and
moreover all the raw data that we get
would not be
really clean it has to be cleaned for
some missing data because somebody
forgot to turn on the switch to record
the data or some wire got tripped over
time so we need to go and clean up the
data fill in the missing data so that it
can be prepared in a form that it can be
used by the downstream analytics so the
working data set that we deal with can
be of the order of 1.8 trillion rows and
therefore that is a lot of data to deal
with so how do we sort of handle it at
scale so let us look at the case of the
graph that I have shown here to explain
the concept so there are two axes in the
graph the vertical axis is called the
capability axis it's actually telling
how fast of a processor you have how
good of a CPU you have so further north
or further up I go along the axis I'm
sort of going towards a supercomputer
realm and I'm sort of like saturating
the processor what is on the horizontal
axis is called the capacity machine
where we actually can increase our
capacity or Kappa City by scaling out
the machines and commissioning more
resources and using them in the case of
data wrangling we are going to process
it typically at a tag voice level
meaning each tag can be taken it can be
filled in for a missing data or
resampled to go and get its answer or we
can deal with a group of tags because
there are some things that physics
governs for example a heat exchanger the
temperature sensor in it is going to be
in sync with the ambient temperature
that's being measured outside I cannot
treat them as independent so we are
going to deal with sensors by itself or
a group of sensors that we would know a
priori based on the physics in either
case this process is pretty well
optimized that's why to process a single
tag or a per tag cost which I've
indicated by the circle over there is
almost further north in the vertical
axis and I've indicated by the circle
over there next if I were to sort of up
get a certain target performance where
we say we want to finish this particular
inline operation in a few hours that
positions where our target performance
for n tags has to go in order to do that
we can come up with how many
since we have to scale out to achieve
the performance later on morally would
actually show a demo of how we were able
to achieve scale up with different nodes
and he will specify the cost and the
speed trade-offs over there
next we'll actually focus on the deep
learning example M knee deep learning
model will actually go through a process
of an architectural search so that we
can actually get the best model we are
striving till the last mile to get an
accurate model because the cost of a
false prediction is pretty steep for the
industrial case what how is it typically
done a subject matter expert would take
and sample different regions he would
decide based on how the model is moving
around how we could tune the different
the number of layers what kind of a drop
what we need to use and other activation
parameters so in the case of bhg in
order if you're going to build like
thousands of models we have automated
this process where we start off with a
sample space that is indicated by the
red crosses that you see over there we
train the deep learning models in the
space and we take the results and we
actually are going to look at certain
outcomes from those models with which we
actually use to fit a model with those
being the outputs and the inputs being
those red crosses that's a meta model
that we built which can be very quickly
queried for other architectures that are
derived from that we go and search the
space of the meta model which is a
surrogate model and come up with the
blue set of dots which is actually the
parrot of friend that indicates the best
choices for the next path of runs so
from that blue curve we can pick a
couple of dots and and we learn the
process couple it along with the
original red Xs to refine the model and
keep on continuing the process so as you
can see this process is a nitrated
process you start off with the red Xs
you come up with your best candidates
which are sitting in your blue curve you
then again refine the model you go again
to the red curve and you keep on pushing
the process till then till the point
where you have sort of happy or you have
enough clear off to the cost versus the
motor
for they are going to put him so in this
case what you see here we looked at a
deep learning model which had around a
10 + architecture parameters that we had
to tune we actually searched over a
quarter-million architectures and the
proof of the pudding is actually in the
result we get so the final answer that
we got out of this process we actually
had a 10x improvement in the training
effectiveness over a model that was done
by a random search by a subject matter
expert next we will sort of look at how
we dealt with some of the process
bottlenecks and how we sort of like
remove them to get the full speed that
we really need to achieve so first we
will start looking at the containers as
we said we build a lot of containers and
that's the box that we show over there
and our containers are encapsulating
different analytics so it can be with
different complexities so some
containers might need GPUs might utilize
them only for a small level say 20% 30%
others might saturate it completely so
so therefore we need or the containers
can actually have much bigger footprint
so if I were to restart the container
every time I'm going to make a run I'm
going to incur a big startup time for
the container if that is a bottleneck in
your building process we could overcome
that by starting the container as a
service where we can actually run an
infinite loop to maintain the container
active we can exit into the container
and sort of run the process and get the
answer back so that's how we can
overcome situations where the containers
actually have a much larger startup time
the second we need to we need to move
data into the container and outside the
container to build models typically the
training data is pretty big so we don't
want to copy information into the
container so the way in which we do it
is the map drive so we avoid copying
huge files into the container and
bringing it out and all the input and
output that as I said before are pretty
well structured so the output we deal
with are the outcomes that we want from
the model those are all exposed as the
JSON files that we'll be able to track
and move it down so that's how we handle
the data and finally more importantly
they said each container is not going to
be using all the resources to its
fullest potential I I should not assign
this container to run on this particular
GPU so what we do here in this case is
we actually run a max case of the
container so that we can determine how
much GPU it utilizes and how much memory
it utilizes knowing that we will be able
to use the fact and schedule multiple
containers to actually run on the same
GPU so it will be able to max out the
GPU that we commissioned so if you sort
of look at the graph I have said
intentionally shown the blue dot to be
on the lower left just to indicate
conceptually that this this analytic
does not use the GPU all by itself fully
so how do we sort of go up further north
and to the east we can actually like use
the fractional resource utilization to
go up north and use more number of GPUs
to go further towards the right and go
towards the start so that is how we'll
be able to achieve the best performance
with all the resources that we
Commission next we will look at the
aspect of orchestrating containers so
the entire process was pretty hydrated
as I said and so the way in which it
starts is we have a node which will
decide what are the next iterations I
need to spawn so it spawns the next set
of iterations after which it actually
has to collate the results and decide if
I have to continue with the next set of
iterations and those intermediate levels
are actually made stateful so that I can
make a decision whether I need to
continue further or not and one of the
things that we noticed was like there's
a limitation of a for loop inside the
cube flow so we had to actually unravel
it and we made it in a form where we
spawn we accumulate we again spawn we
accumulate the process to continue it
and get the results so in order to sort
of reach the full potential of all the
resources we commissioned we had to use
this fractional GPU allocation so that
we can get a near linear scale up for
the resources that we have I will
quickly show the results at the end
after moraly finishes part thanks
yeah thanks mother sorry as my Devon
said we are in Ireland gas industry and
we are not a digital native industry
there is a vast difference between
digital native industry and an island
gas industry the usually the data we get
from digital native industry is rich and
it is almost ready to be consumable but
in Ireland gas industry we collect the
data or last 30 years and it can be very
messy and very often we don't even know
what we are looking for ok so unless we
explore so the exploration stage of the
data itself is quite different from the
digital metal in the industries and it
is highly iterative and we have to
iterate so many times like till the data
scientists come back and say that yes
now the data is consumable so I mean
some of you may be like me maybe from a
traditional data
background and scale up was the solution
but now we have scaled out and the
kubernetes really comes as a great
rescue greatest fear here ok so here I
would like to show I mean so for the
last couple of years are more than that
we have been a very heavy Cuban it is
sharp and we use Cuban it is extensively
both on Prem and on various cloud
platforms and we have a heterogeneous
environment so we have been managing
this Cuban in clusters on Prem and some
of the challenges some of you know that
the patch management is the biggest
hassle and we need to take down time and
we need to go back to the data
scientists and them modern will be very
frustrated that we bring these clusters
down in the middle of a big exploration
model development and the two other has
is what we have seen so far is the auto
scaling auto scaling is not available I
mean it's a it's not
easy to implement it on pram and the and
then the cost okay it's not
cost-effective we if we are fixed with
100 notes you have to continue to
consume all the hundred notes then we
started recently migrating to G g CP and
we have been using G K here the biggest
advantage as you can see the under
dashboard here this has been made
possible because we used stackdriver and
g CP so we collect the matrix at a
granular level and this is in fact a
cluster of clusters and we can
immediately see which node is coming up
which node is being shut down is being
spun down and so we can continuously
monitor it okay this is made possible
only because we run it on g CP
the other aspect is the management of
the cluster okay now we don't have to
worry we have a small DevOps team and
they are now relieved and mind Mahadevan
can spend more time on his model
development rather than maintaining the
clusters the third aspect is cost okay
because we proficient them only when
it's needed we don't spend as much money
as we used to do before
I'll make I'll have a simple demo here
before we go to the demo let me explain
here so we took a simple query one of
the simplest of simple queries as soon
as we received the data that's about 55
billion rows and when we ran it with 10
nodes the it was costing typically like
$1 ok and when we scaled it up to 40
nodes we'll finish the job
in hundred and thirty seconds as against
700 seconds and the cost came down by
twenty twenty eight percent so this is
where we we we become a differentiator
because we finish the job in far less
time and we achieve it at far less cost
as well okay
so this is the I hope the demo gods help
me so this as you can see this is a
cluster of 40 nodes okay and this is the
running average one of the simplest of
simple queries that we do as soon as we
receive that our data from the customers
so we can see the progress of the query
it's against 40 nodes sorry yeah just
refreshed it and let me forward it in
the interest of time so as you can see
here it's 55 billion rows 55 billion
rows we could complete it in two minutes
and nine seconds and the cost of the
query is less than $1 okay that's what
we achieve and this is against 55
billion rows and as mataman said
typically for a well or for a simple
equipment what we take it when we
expanded it it goes to 1.8 trillion
records so so we experiment this with
with a less number of nodes and then as
the need arises we scale up and that's
how we achieve the the at a cheaper rate
thanks Marty
so I'll quickly summarize the results
from the the auto-scaling experiment
that we did so where we actually take
look at the graph over here where we are
trying to increase the number of GPUs
and we can sort of see whether we are
able to roll leverage and utilize it
completely at all so look at the bottom
two graphs so what you see on the right
side is the number of GPU nodes where we
are doing an experiment where we are
able to actually increase or in a preset
manner the number of GPU goes from 1 to
2 to 3 all the way till 8 and what you
see on the left side the lower left is
actually telling how we are able to
utilize the GPU so if we start off with
1 GPU beginning and then we ramp it from
1 to 2 you can immediately see the
percentage utilization drops to 50 and
it again kicks up and almost goes up
instantaneously 200 percent the next
step when I go from 2 to 3 you can sort
of see it docking down and again goes up
200% so the main takeaway from here is
the way in which we did the fractional
utilization and we are able to assign it
to the GPUs we are able to nearly assign
full utilization as we increase the
number of GPUs and more importantly as
we take the GPUs away we're also able to
ramp it down so this one just summarizes
how we're able to show auto scaling
works when we ramp up and ramp down the
GPUs the next case is how we actually
make it work on the gke so in this
experiment what we did was we had a 32
node cluster and instead of actually
allowing the cluster to operate or go up
to 100% we preset the limit that it
reaches so to 80% so once we load up the
machine as we sort of shown by the
experiment 1 and because we are capping
it off at 80% the number of node
requirement actually jumps
instantaneously from 32 - all the way to
40 it's pretty much flat and once our
load tapers down it releases the GPUs
and comes back again just to see the
repeatability we again fired the process
again so that is the experiment - where
we fired the same process with the same
constraints 80% as your threshold and as
you can see the GPU nodes which got
commissioned automatically
actually increased to 40 and then it
came down for the third experiment what
we did was we wanted to simulate a case
where we partially permit an increase
and then due to some other case we're
actually taking the GPUs away from the
system too so we capped it off initially
to a some intermediate number and then
slowly started removing the GPUs from
the system to see how it responds as you
can see it got capped over there and we
sort of like brought down the GPUs in a
preset sequence in the bottom right as
you can see at the top the time it took
to sort of complete the entire process
actually expanded along the horizontal
so again in order to maintain a high GPU
Talese ation we need to have a good way
of orchestrating and you need to design
the underlying containers to respect
that and so that you'll be able to
leverage it fully so in summary if I
were to like summarize the best
practices the cloud scalability actually
requires a lot of planning on how you
build the containers how you understand
how much resources it needs and manage
it and definitely look for a lot of
redesign and I trait of steps that needs
to happen and finally for load balancing
the fractional GP utilisation and other
things has to be adhered to so that you
can use the resources fulling expo day1
i'd like to say a couple of things here
scaling up is not panacea I mean it can
be sometimes it will end up as a brute
force and it has T it is highly
iterative a lot of patience and planning
is required and load balancing is
another aspect you got to think about it
very carefully and adaptive space be
prepared to have some space so that you
can redesign your architecture and take
a different route a totally different
route and from where you started
it's not easy I mean now that you have
Kuban it is a particular land gke it's
mermaid much more simpler now for
example scaling up is much more simple
right now for example typically scaling
up about 200
it it happens in now less than a minute
so so you got to have lot of space to
adapt to the changes but you can do like
many things with kubernetes yeah thanks
Thank You Maude Thank You Mahadevan and
only for sharing your insightful
experiences with us today so let's
summarize the key takeaways so at Google
our mission is very simple we want to
empower your team to drive innovation by
making a IML simple fast and
cost-effective we are making MML simple
by offering data scientists they're
friendly notebooks we are freeing them
up from managing the infrastructure and
also providing higher level abstractions
like tier tensorflow jobs and then
several servings so that their work
becomes super simple we are making a IML
fast by offering you on-demand scale up
and scale down and also hardware
accelerators like GPUs and CPUs and we
are making AML cost-effective by making
your team's more productive with
advanced tooling and wining the vendor
locking with open platforms like
kubernetes and crew flow and many other
things we have developed in Google are
available in open source environment
this way you can write once and run
anywhere and finally but most important
you have preemptable GPUs and CPUs to
further lower the cost for your batch
workloads
[Music]